maman c'est en effet une confirmation de
plus le gouvernement ne veut pas dérapé
sur le front des salaires comme je vous
l'annoncé hier soir michel rocard a bien
rencontré lui même la nuit dernière une
délégation des infirmières en grève mais
les 13 heures de négociations entre le
ministre de la santé
les syndicats d'un côté la coordination
d'autres n'ont pas abouti les
infirmières demandent une augmentation
de 2000 francs par mois le gouvernement
en proposant moyenne 600 francs dans les
hôpitaux en grève aujourd'hui c'était
l'effervescence des assemblées générales
christophe martet s'était décrit avant
même le vote
la grève continue dans les hôpitaux au
moins jusqu'à lundi la méthode rocard
n'a semble-t-il pas convaincu les
infirmières
le soir quand on entend d'information
500 francs six enfants est très
enthousiaste et quand on se rend compte
le matin ce que c'est son oeil de paye
on est déçu oui par exemple pourrait
faire une insertion et 200 francs
solaire de l'acte et après des primes
longue dans 15 ans pour commencer
autant sur la lassitude et a permis
répond potro
qu'est-ce que
le gouvernement a tout de même besoin de
certaines voire pour être élu au 6 1
on n'a pas fait partie des gens qui ont
voté contre eux aujourd'hui les autres
catégories personnel des laborantins aux
aides soignants frustré de jouer les
second rôles sont encore plus mobilisés
que les infirmières font rien ne pourra
marcher si on n'est pas en forme si on
n'arrive pas à trouver une entente à 100
parce qu en 10 ans le prix du bel même
privés de haut niveau demande qu'en soit
fall de lainage trois jours suite à
allier aux infirmiers demain la
coordination nationale des infirmières
se réunira et même si la grève a été
reconduite dans les hôpitaux on
s'indignera sur sa position
seul